hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i wanted to talk a
little bit about what's happening within
the cryptocurrency and the world of
bitcoin and also why so many
entrepreneurs right now
are diversifying from cryptocurrency
into property investment so a little
disclaimer
i have i do sometimes um invest a little
bit into cryptocurrency
i have invested into bitcoin i invested
a few years ago into bitcoin
however i am not by any stretch of the
imagination
an expert when it comes to crypto
currencies or bitcoin
i am my skills my professionalism my
expertise
fall in property investment real estate
that's what i know
that's what i love now what seems to be
happening with bitcoin
i mean like anything like property or
you know you see
you see the pattern of up down up down
up down and right now what's happening
with bitcoin is it's crashing
and it's crashed massively over the over
the last few days
um i first bought bitcoin for seven
thousand pounds that was my first coin
i bought a couple of coins and now the
prize today as
as i'm speaking on the 20th of may or
thursday the 20th of may
um it stands around 27 000 pounds so
it's gone up considerably
however a few weeks ago it was i think
did it even hit 50
i think it hit 50 something crazy but as
it's crashing what people are doing now
it's gone
up and as it began to fall a lot of
people started to sell
they started to sell their bitcoin they
were cashing in and now they're
diversifying into property
um there was other a lot of people i
know people have got rich off things
like dodge coin dodge coin was created
as a joke
there's an unlimited amount of coins
that you can that you can create
uh yet people literally um bought coins
and then they just went up
crazy crazy amounts and it's a really
interesting business because ultimately
you know when there's fear and the
prices start falling and as more people
start getting fearful
the price drops drop stops drops and
then when it gets really low people go
it's quite long and they start buying
and people get greedy and then it goes
up
and that's what happens the cycle um so
i wrote an article actually on
for entrepreneur magazine which you can
check out below and it's my thoughts on
why people are
transitioning right now from and
diversifying from cryptocurrency
to property to real estate if you want
to check out that
um article you can check it out in the
description below
but i think this is the thing when i
talk about property i always say
don't buy for capital appreciation
if you're buying a house you want to buy
for
rent that way if it goes up or if it
goes down
it doesn't really matter because you're
still getting your passive income you're
still getting your rent
now the problem with bitcoin is
that's not quite the case it doesn't
give you any rent
so people are buying it in the hope
that it will go up now will it go up i
imagine probably eventually it will
i imagine probably eventually it will i
think i i think but at the same time it
could not
it could go down to nothing the truth is
we just don't know
and when the experts disagree you know
everyone everyone seems to be a crypto
expert these days
on social media um but but the truth is
i i don't know okay i can't i can't
predict exactly what's gonna happen
you might get rich you might not so my
advice would be this
firstly if you are going to invest in
cryptocurrency
probably invest what you can afford to
lose um
diversify as much as possible the great
thing about property is you've got an
asset
which you can touch and feel which will
probably hold its value because it has
for
you know thousands of years so it's
probably going to hold its value it's
probably going to go up in value
but it's also going to give you rent so
if you're smart at the moment and
you you are you're diversified i've seen
a lot of smart people that
where they've made crazy money on these
coins like dodge coin
and now as they're crashing they're
they're taking their profits
they're investing it into property uh
which i think is which i think is a
smart move and then no doubt
when the time is right they'll probably
reinvest back into kryptos
uh when they think it's gonna start
going crazy high again it seems that
elon musk
when elon musk says and when he went
elon musk went and bought 1.5
billion pounds worth of bitcoin uh and
everyone was like oh my gosh and then
bitcoin
price went crazy because well if it's
good enough
for elon musk it's good enough for
everybody right and then elon musk then
sold a few
or when he says right i'm not we're not
accepting cryptocurrency
in exchange for tesla cars anymore and
then suddenly everyone got scared and
followed like
sheep so it's a really interesting world
um i highly would check
uh check out the article i wrote for
entrepreneur magazine as i say that is
in the description check it out i'd love
to know your thoughts
let me know your thoughts as well are
you invested in cryptocurrency
um are you diversifying into property
uh let me know in the comments what you
think what do you think bitcoin's gonna
do do you think it's gonna crash
do you think it's gonna become worth a
million pounds per coin
again i'd love to know your thoughts in
the comments also i'm very open to
a debate or a discussion so if there's
anybody in particular that you'd love to
see
me have a conversation a discussion or a
debate with
on this topic let me know and we can
absolutely make it happen
so that's my thoughts check out the
article it's in the description and i'll
see you next time
peace